ladies and gentlemen meet Canyon is back
on the show today I am back if you can't
tell already and we have an announcement
to make
sex with each other
Gus is our bottom yeah Gus is the silly
bottom don't call me Gus for nothing
what's the announcement can you really
make it
we have a new podcast series coming out
called the meat locker limited series
limited series limited series it's how
many episodes six episodes
and get this
we have some really great guests coming
on really horny guests we should preface
that right yeah is that a way of
describing it
silly guess
something like that yeah the
conversations did tend to skew
a bit inappropriate in that way we got
some great guests on we have David
Blaine on the show Chuck E cheese that
was a good news good to talk to him Babe
Ruth I was actually very excited to talk
to Babe Ruth yeah yeah that was really
cool it was a good one Scooby-Doo as
well yeah we got Scooby-Doo coming on so
first episode comes out on Monday and
then uh it'll be every Monday after that
for six Mondays so hopefully you can
stand that for six weeks
and it'll be on the TMG feed so you
don't have to look anywhere else folks
yeah it'll be right here right here as
soon as you see that thumbnail you're
going to think to yourself
when is this going to be over
people on YouTube like viewers on
YouTube are just blatantly just kind of
the worst people
on earth
because they don't ever want anything
different they just want you to do the
same thing over and over and over and
over and over and over again yeah and
then after a while their idiot brain
thinks God he never does anything
different yeah so then they leave you
yeah yeah you're like I gave you what
you want and now you hate me over here
like
40 button videos later he's like
they don't want anything different
no they don't dude I still like I met
people last week they were like they
were like you guys
to the button
no I I met some fan and she was like
please don't stop doing button videos
and I was like
what the [ __ ] is a button video
listen to me has there been 40 buttons
training you mustn't stop okay okay
or I will find you I'll tell you what
bro kill you you're competing with
[ __ ] Mr Beast and all the new
channels and stuff what do you mean just
new Ventures all the time oh thanks just
so all sorts of things I actually wanted
to Fanboy over you a little bit hey go
ahead dude if you don't mind what do you
want to say well I mean I feel like when
we met
you were like trying to figure out your
second Channel and now you got that [ __ ]
ironed out you're doing videos like
three times a week on there you got one
on the main Channel every week no more
less than that I don't know but you know
it's enough it's enough
um no yeah and it just seems like you're
doing a lot by the way dude when you met
me I knew I figured myself out
just fine
all right no I'm just saying that so
when you said that I was you know type
toeing around trust me bro these two
feet were planted Stern into the [ __ ]
ground and I knew my who I was I said
you were ironing out your second Channel
nothing it was already a silk smooth
blanket all right nothing too iron not
one wrinkle to be had
all right you hit you were like dude how
do I get this monetized I don't know
what's going on well we don't need to
devolve into it
yes we do
you called me you were in tears you were
into you're crying yeah
you said Uncle I saw you called me uncle
Cody I saw you do 17 different things
and I'm just trying to figure out how do
I do I don't know two he said how do I
do my mutton video what do I do yeah and
um and he said easy
that's why I stopped calling him because
he would start he's everything I would
say hey man how you doing
easy down
let me tell you how you do this yep come
on down there water buffalo exactly it's
all right easy
shh I stopped going to his house because
every time I've been to L.A anytime I
I'll tweet out or I'll do something once
again me Canon on Instagram Twitter
right and by the way
I like to go out there and I like to say
I'm in LA and who what's the first phone
call I get Cody please go to my house
please come over here what
I'm smoking meats and I want you to come
over
and then I went over once and the whole
time he was just like shoulder rubs
Kelsey was doing all kinds of crazy
things I I stopped going what was she
doing I'm not going to get into it
because I was uncomfortable and I don't
want severe to be uncomfortable so I
stopped going okay so I put these things
out and he doesn't know I blocked his
number
well you stopped calling me I did I did
so what the hell but I did hit you up on
Instagram because you were in Austin and
I was like why the [ __ ] you know this is
I live here yeah
not one text or anything
I damned you that where you were at I
live 10 minutes away
it's like kind of like a soprano
sandwich like they respect
yeah yeah hey I'm in Austin Well I love
it here maybe to check in with you a
little bit okay
so I think you know what if because
everybody lives in La content creator
wise right yeah I would say so it's like
if someone goes to La I really don't
have to like text someone be like hey
bro I'm here whatever unless I you know
you're like have plans or something but
if you don't like other people how you
let me know when you're in L.A every
time he sends me a private uh like IG
photo where he's like
that's true I'm usually it's usually I'm
shirtless in the airplane bathroom yeah
on the plane
and he puts a little text he's like
coming to La what are you doing yeah
biscuits are in the oven
the yams are hot
I always just get Peach emojis and
flames and stuff like that afterwards
yeah I don't get them because you
blocked me because it's blocked because
of what happened the first time I went
to your house
and we don't talk about the rub down I
know okay well no but can I also say the
the merch video that you did was awesome
it's so [ __ ] creative thank you and
really cool and just like a really I
don't know genius idea you know uh
took a while to make those udders
I'm just going to leave a little
breadcrumb Trail for that because otters
what yeah they're there and they do
shoot milk
so yeah yeah that was great it was a
good it was a good time a lot of good
merch too which is actually kind of fun
if you go to meetcanion.store there's
actually all sorts of just like just
awesome pieces of
just great clothing and I mean like
posters and that's really coloring books
and sketchbooks and stuff and they are
affordable are they we don't have to
show it nobody no go ahead put it up he
gives a [ __ ] you're gonna see those
you're gonna see those prices dude they
have all kinds of sizes they have double
XL triple XL quadruple XL 5xl my fan
base loves it those big sizes sell out
immediately yeah you know what if
somebody's saying I'm on a medium shirt
don't even [ __ ] show up to the store
dude I want big old boys and big old
girls that's all I want to do yeah all
right so if someone's like I want a
petite small buy how about you go to
American Eagle dude does someone do
people still haven't shopped there look
at that photo if you got a petite sexy
body head over to tmg.com
we got petite boy and girl merch hey if
you're seven years old go to tmg.com and
get your merch we got a little Gus merch
your name is Gus please feel free to go
if you have a silly daddy in your name
dude I was I was pissed because your
guys you're the fabric of your merch
feels so good but like trying to get
into it was insane I was like like I
felt like I was getting to a wetsuit
when I put on my shirt
and it's like that's what it's made out
of neoprene all of our merch is neoprene
you're supposed to you're supposed to
deep diving fishing
Lobster hunting yeah exactly whenever
you're diving here on lobsters you need
to wear the merch that's weird we sent
you a double X it didn't fit oh
absolutely not no tight tight that was a
Euro double yeah it must be a petite
double X that's what it was yeah yeah
double X yeah
I'm small but I'm big yeah that's what I
say every morning in the mirror just
like yeah I'm small but I'm big I'm
small but I'm big and click your heels
together
[Laughter]
I'm small but I'm big